der sneaker als mike happy day trader
etwas glaubt willkommen beim neuen video
ja weil ich hoffe euch jetzt gut ich
habe heute nach einem monat mal wieder
mein bruder aber es gilt ich hoffe dir
jetzt auch gut wie es auf jeden fall bin
ich gerade mal wieder zu hause bei
meinen eltern und ich habe mir gedacht
ich könnte eigentlich heute mal wieder
was mit ihr anstellen
und zwar habe ich mir etwas ganz
besonderes überlegt wie immer und zwar
habe ich das mal auf youtube gesehen da
haben einfach irgendwelche youtuber so
songs erwarten also einfach so zitaten
aus diesen songs vorgelesen und dann
muss halt der andere erraten was das für
song ist also von welchem youtuber die
saison ist weil du weißt ja viele
youtube machen songs zum beispiel bricht
die sind sehr gut und viele leute
schauen sich das warum noch sie jetzt
wenn ich weiß ich weil er gut sind auf
jeden fall habe ich mir das ein bisschen
anders überlegt und zwar bin ich
hingegangen und habe mir songs
rausgesucht ja wirklich schlecht
bewertet sind ich muss sagen ich finde
gar nicht jeden song den ich euch
gleichzeitig oder die ich dir zeige
schlecht als natürlich sind jetzt nicht
die mega chance aber sie werden halt
irgendwie so schlecht bewertet als das
sind fast alles sonst die deutlich mehr
displays haben als likes und ja die zeit
jetzt gleich und dafür habe ich mir
jetzt folgendes überlegt damit du das ja
nicht sofort erregt werde ich die
rückwärts abspielen dass man kann auf
jeden fall erkennen welcher song es ist
wenn man ihn schon mal gehört hat aber
ich sage im vorfeld schon mal das ich
das du youtuber songs jetzt nicht umhin
kenne so allgemein deswegen werden wir
sehen also eigentlich so du musst
mindestens vier davon musst du kann also
ich habe sechs rausgesucht viel davon
wenn du nicht kennst dann bin ich echt
enttäuscht auch hier kein youtube gucken
ja darauf gab es auf keinen fall jetzt
hier reingucken sagen wir bei 15.000
likes machen alles sommer mit guten
songs okay so mit mir kann ja zum
beispiel in auggen
ich würde sagen wir fangen erst mal ganz
leicht an damit du das also sinnvoll
musst du können
du musst ihn einfach kennen bist du dich
dann geht jetzt komplett von hinten wo
genau die wenigsten verdrücken was
abgeschaut von hinten um rückwärts
genommen 321 gau
ja
[Applaus]
die last auf jeden fall mal sofort bei
jedem song in den kommentaren mit
schreibt zu eins erst nicht und dann
bleibe was zu sagen das ist weil kennst
du das nicht
[Applaus]
ich werde ein bisschen vor mich sehr
stört noch nicht das ist das meist die
displays von abriss erst von ihm was
also raus kann man so todes gehisst
wurde foto show
nein dachte erst ich bin hätte ich nicht
gedacht dass musste kennen nur mal
gucken ob du das jetzt kann das kind das
wir auch nicht
mehr
[Musik]
ja du bist ein
du denkst du bist steckt also möchte ich
ein gewaltiges kaesberg ist man nicht
tun
ich weiß zwar viel bin davon also den
kannst du auch zu hundert mal gucken ob
ich den song könnt welche stimme
weißt du solltest sich auflösenden
machen wir hier ja aber den song ich
glaube der hat auch je 100000 dollar
gemietet haben dann guckt ganz richtig
zeit verschwenden
das musste jetzt eigentlich sofort
erraten 321 bitteschön
[Applaus]
der kippe
das ist mal lustig dass es eigentlich
anhören
[Musik]
schön dass sie hier falsch
ich bin wirklich jeder song jetzt hier
rückwärts abgespielt wird hört sich
richtig japanisch oder chinesisch
[Applaus]
wir kommen jetzt zum fünften song bis
juli
[Musik]
ich sag dir einfach mal drei youtuber
die frage kommen
ich würde mal sagen erstens catherine
2/3 zu lenken
ich habe alle drei niemand nimmt immer
fresh juice mit dem jesus du hast wie
viele views
ich habe eine million und kann bald in
der villa wohnen irgendwie so gibt es
das heißt du hast jetzt von fünf songs 2
erwarten daher nun den von ja das ist
auf jeden fall ne hammer quote sorgen
über die weitere ports und ich will noch
ein zeigen kommen letzten noch ein
letztes thema nochmal rein wenn man sagt
ja aber ich wollte war mir erst und sich
dann mit rheine wenn du alle so schnell
hätte ich den auch nicht mit rein müssen
neuer band sagt
[Applaus]
wenn es um ein auto geht auch irgendwie
geht alles ums auto entfernen
ja ich kenne das nicht ich kenne den
namen setzen
wer jetzt kommt es nur noch das wort das
filz weise auch wenn sie bitte ich war
ein paar wochen einmal so werden die
namen so ok ich hätte mir das du bist ja
das waren jetzt sechs songs herzlichen
glückwunsch stößt auf jeden fall alles
gegeben und zwei davon sogar geraten
hätte ich gedacht wenn euch das video
gefeiert dass auf jeden fall nach oben
da und abonniert auf jeden fall den
kanal und folgt mein bruder mal auf
instagram leute schaut auf jeden fall
mal mehr ins team vorbei und hast du
vielleicht mal von oder dann hat er bald
wieder 15.000 und wir sehen uns dann
übermorgen wieder oder vielleicht schon
morgen keine ahnung snapshot ernster
genommen war bei mir auch gesagt bin ich
rein